[Music]
the title of Grand Master was first
officially awarded in 1950 now in 2017
at the st. Louis Winter Invitational
that tradition continues hello chess
fans and welcome back to st. Louis for
day two of the 2017 Winter Invitational
today we play two rounds of chess in the
GM and I am norm tournament fields now
in this tournament the up-and-coming
players who don't yet have their
perspective titles are going at it with
the guys who already do and if they have
a performance usually six and a half out
of nine or better then they will get one
of the benchmarks one of the norms out
of three to get that title stick with us
right here on YouTube over the next week
as we talk to some of the hopefuls some
of whom have come from all over the
world to participate in this truly
international event for seven players
the objective earn a norm
however the means to doing that differs
for each player for six and a half
points gore vets liang burke ali mirandy
and Kumar can earn a GM norm for only
six points
Cheka and Abraham Ian can earn a GM norm
and additionally Believe It or Not for
four and a half points Kumar and Abraham
Ian are eligible for an IM norm in this
section all right joining me now is feat
a master justice Williams the famous
justice Williams I think we've all in
the chess world heard of him by now and
today with the black pieces he defeated
Aaron grab insky justice first of all
congratulations take us through some
moments of this game okay all right so
before the game even started my opponent
showed up pretty late you want to get a
half an hour before you forfeit it and
he showed up like 29 minutes late so I
was pretty glad that he showed up
because
yeah I didn't want a portal win so he
got into a standard of London
position and I just went into a clean be
six I was hoping that he would actually
exchange Queens and I was thinking uh
this position was pretty farm for black
uh knowing Aaron I know like he he wants
to play aggressive even he must play
aggressively he plays the London so it's
like it's a I just know that if I play
solid that I he'll try to just come to
me for sharing so even though I wanted
this position I know he wasn't really
gonna go into this position because it
just seems too solid for black it's not
much here for white I could probably
play either east six or Bishop f5
probably bishop at five is better here
ninety-five maybe Brooke a5 a4 and I can
play either east six or probably just
Bishop c2 and yeah I think black is
doing pretty well here
maybe Bishop e6 or something like that
so yeah and if he plays a normal move
like Knight d2 you can't really stop the
pawn push and
this position is pretty good for blood
Adri just be for anyways and this is
pretty pretty comfortable from like so
instead he played Queen c2 actually
actually spent a lot of time in this
position when I was preparing it just
looking at Queen b6
I like that Queen c2 for like a minute
but I didn't see anything too dangerous
with it I just oh such a simple plate
but I still hate it from right here is
for me
it's just I'm out on my prep and I'm
just playing regular chest
I play h6 h3 e6 and then now I'm just
playing for equality so I'm just gonna
play Queen b8 am I playing a playing
Bishop to d6 I was actually expecting 95
I'll probably just play rook c8 oh wait
at first I was gonna play like she ate I
didn't think he played 95 right away so
if I move like Bishop e2 I'll just play
Bishop d6 and this position is pretty
solid for black I think black has all
the chances here and it's
this probably something he saw as well
and he just chose not to go into it but
the way this this is pretty solid for a
white as well it shouldn't be a general
you played 95 and I've seen a couple of
games d65 is pretty bad here you just
play 97 and Knight goes to c5 and then I
goes to d3 and it's just pretty bad for
white and I goes to see father this is
or maybe Bishop here and this is pretty
bad probably has efore I don't really
calculate this much before and I was
thinking probably I could take on e4 or
I could just move the bishop I wasn't
too sure which was better I'm thinking
Bishop g6 is probably better just
keeping the well if I've played pawn
takes e4 he has some play now and he has
deep for those a d6 squares and my plan
was to put pressure on e5 pawn but he
has two defenders now so I should
probably just play with some g6 and
and then plane I see fog next move for
him to take on d5 or something like that
and I and I still call it sea forth so I
took 95 bishop takes and then Bishop d6
I was expecting just takes here on d6
and you know like I said before it's
just uh I'm fine I'm content with well
I'm come to help with the trailer here
um yeah if night of 3 I was looking
maybe I just Bishop before here
threatening to take on after I take any
five and just fortunate to take this
anyways 95 probably just castle like
it's probably a little better like has
the beef the pawn push the pawn storm be
585 before and why it just has to find a
way to hold I think I should pretty much
hold up in its position but he took on
up six and I know I think he's I know
there was a chance he had probably taken
out six simply because I know he's just
an aggressive player especially with
white but he gave me the two bishops and
I was pretty happy with that
after cast as I was really hoping for
like Knight takes I thought pawn takes
and then my two pawns in the center
they're just gonna steamroll um I didn't
really consider casters points out much
probably they should be to either f4 or
rook e8 I guess I could go F for cats
whose after is good right
yeah after years pretty much money and
yeah it's Queen d2 probably just 48
castles after he again so he'd probably
have to Castle queenside and f3 again
and this is just pretty much bad it
wasn't a queen here so I was pretty
happy with my position especially up
tonight takes at five but Aaron is a
good player so he didn't play night six
and five he played Queen d2 and I was
really considering just some castling
queenside I really took castling
queenside seriously I was and free in
this position I debated on three moves
for like 10-15 minutes and all of them
were pretty much fun and I don't know
why I did that
and I ended up playing like the weaker
of the moves I believe I was looking at
either rugby eight and so if castles I
was expecting like a default push which
never really came I just thought d5 in
this position would have been okay um
Bishop here and I said if I make a move
like this I was always expecting d5 I
thought this was like his the best
chance for play it never really came and
I didn't want to commit my rook to
either d8 because if he castles King
side I would want my effort on EI and my
a work on d8
but uh if he can show his Queen side I
would want my F work on d8 and my a work
on c8 so I didn't really want to commit
any of my rooks yet so I play kh8
because I saw in a lot of those lines
later on the e6 pawn becomes a trouble
so I just wanted to get the King out of
check it without committing marks and
sure enough your Castle queenside and
then like it's a hit my rooks in the
correct position
look f1 his his whole play kind of
surprised me here cuz he he's an
aggressive player but he didn't really
play aggressively in this type of
position he played rook f1 like
threatening f3 and stuff but that's d5
is the movie I was expecting here and
just something more aggressive than what
he played like rook up one didn't really
hit fear in my heart right so you just
played a rook F one I played Queen g5
now help f3
especially before and this is pretty
nasty from it's just not something white
would want to get into him um so he
played g3 Queen h5 attacking another
pawn not allowing him to play at three I
just take it so played age four
yeah and I was just able to do whatever
I wanted in this position
I still think white is fine black is
better but white is not there is no way
that white is losing in this position
and I'm not sure about the move came to
one because Kimmy one just allows before
it just invites before and I didn't
think that was the best thing for him
probably just like maybe a tree making
me play 8 v was probably better um like
I said I like the move d5 and it just
never came
maybe d5 in this position isn't so great
just fish it takes like pawn takes and
yeah I just want to pawn now Bishop
takes a [ __ ] take d5 and I have Recife
and it should be pretty good for black
oh it takes f7 yeah just work 62 oh I
guess not for it take Z tooth and has
[ __ ] takes H bar and yeah I don't
really see but should take d1 yes
so yeah I guess d5 I guess my dad was
right that default should be played
sooner or later like I just I don't know
I don't know why he didn't just stop
playing aggressive and it just allowed
me to work I probably just played with
some g6 or something
it's pretty hard yeah he can't move any
in his pieces really so I guess this is
okay but I thought I'd probably have
rook c5 at first but I guess I thought
he didn't want to see this again she
takes f7 yeah I guess I I don't have it
so yeah um yeah but should be six now
I'm turning V for things like that he
plays King a1 he invites before I play
it nice e4 it takes on c3
not here I'm pretty happy here the
knight is not only three anymore so I
could possibly push III soon the king is
a little weak and I wasn't too sure how
I was gonna win but I knew that black
was better here Queen goes to e3
stopping III I didn't I didn't like his
the way his pieces to replace so I just
played a fire couldn't be father might
be to stopping a for and here is one
like like you know you have a good
position but you don't know how to win
so I wasn't too sure how to win but he
really just made it easy for me after
Bishop e6 f4 I'm not sure what this was
about
so yeah I'm not sure what this was about
I left for politics to paint takes I
spent a lot of time in this position
debating after rook takes what to do I
think I probably just still go over to
c7 something like that
I wasn't too sure about that I should
put it work c7 or a move like Bishop g6
then I was afraid of moves like g4 and
then I probably have to play h5 and this
isn't something that I probably should
do I was also thinking about like Bishop
g8 in each type of positions so now I
could play f-16 and stop and check make
threats but he also has to his attack
and it works as well so I have to
consider that as well and plus I just
like this Bishop on this diagonal
stopping every piece from going on to
the B file it's just hard for him to
play it just it causes a lot of problems
but he ended up playing Queen takes it
this was kind of a suspect move I think
it takes was more flexible I played with
g7 defending up 7 look do you want yeah
here I was expecting to you for I and I
think G Force might be the best
they try - e5 sacrificing a pawn but
just opening up the age file and
creating some type of counter play and
he just never played aggressively here
oh yeah he just played rugby 1 and so I
was getting a little more time so I just
decided to stop thinking I was like I
have to push for an attack sooner or
later so I just push after Bishop takes
I probably just play 25 if it should be
3 just rook a 7 I mean there's nothing
really concrete here but um just with
there's just a lot of pressure by black
in this position in it I was fine with
it I didn't really see anything but as
long as I have pressure then that's fine
probably like two for 25 Knight takes
plane takes soonly he probably just
placating me to here and something like
this was I thought this was pretty good
for me
see for Hobby just for v8 now
and King a one and well might right here
is Queen B for oh wait might but his
quaint X 82 sorry and so yeah here
probably play King here oh I wasn't so
sure if I should probably just product
try to get the bishop in a game now or
something like that but this position
doesn't seem bad for black at all X III
and it's just it's a lot of things that
went on here probably Bishop T tool is
good what takes never take beat degree
well I'm not sure if it's good but it's
just it's just a lot of things going on
in this position that he has to take
account of probably lurking I like this
move actually this was this move looks
pretty cool now I'm I try this coin
takes a tool and I think that's pretty
cool so I probably would have played
this rug d2
I think it's pretty good with like even
look like it's down to falling but it's
a heartful way to play here but yeah I
saved this move Knight takes e4 I don't
really consider it much I just thought
it was losing and like pretty close wait
on the spot really not learning to take
on a four because best move was Quinn f1
for sure and it's probably Elise into
the same thing as before probably have
to play kinky to this is probably a
worse version of this and then just rook
to b8 and I think black is going more
than fine here now 24 hour could
probably play like that should be four
and now my bishop goes to d5 and it's in
the game and yeah this is pretty it's
just something like it's hoping for and
I just know c4 on the spot was but he
just played c4 c4 just special takes d4
and this is pretty much game over yeah
and I have pasty pawn all up in exchange
and this can't be
yeah this is pretty hard for white to
hold so he's just resigned in this
position but this wasn't Aaron's best
game and this wasn't my best game um but
uh there was just a lot of chances for
him that he just never take advantage of
I guess this is one of my more lucky
games simply from the fact that he
showed up 29 minutes late and I'm glad
that he showed up at that 29 minute
just that he didn't take advantage of
the moves that he could have I just
think this was a pretty lucky game I
guess lucky or not a win is a win right
justice and and even though we're really
early on you are you are already in the
clear lead at two points even if it's
just by half a point so that is
something to talk about and also you
have to I am norms so this could be the
big event tell us about your
expectations for this tournament I mean
I have a little joke going we are in and
stuff I told them that was gonna get you
in a half right now I think I'm looking
pretty good but now it's just about
playing it's just playing good chess
playing the best move as well just
playing the best moves in a position and
say I think if I keep playing on pretty
solid moves or the best moves in my
games and I should do pretty well here
it's just about playing the best moves
in in one game it's just taking each
game just taking it one game at a time
and I mean I can't I can't be mad at
myself
chess is a young man's game increasingly
and a lot of the players in this
tournament our students including
yourself how are your studies at Webster
if they are how are they affecting this
tournament well I mean well I miss
obviously
well first I'm missing school for this
tournament I don't know it missing a
couple of classes but other than that I
guess for me it's easy to balance I do a
lot of reading and you can't I mean you
can't be upset that you get to do what
you love like you have to do what you
love like if I love to read and I'm
gonna read and I'm just glad I'm taking
classes that are helping me read um but
yeah just being being able to come to
Webster was a great opportunity
there's a lot of chess going on around
here
I get to study here and it's just an
amazing opportunity for me and I'm just
glad to have received this opportunity
yeah well justice good luck on the rest
of the tournament it's a been a pleasure
having you and there are two rounds
being played today so let's take a look
at the standings after the I am norm
section round three seven players in
this field eligible for a north
however the means to get there is
different for each player for six and a
half points
Rabbids ki hua Benoa colas williams and
shankar will earn an IM norm and due to
the tougher field he will face Doug
Eckert only has to get six points to
earn his I am north the 2017 st. Louis
winter Invitational continues through
Tuesday February the 21st follow all of
the action including the live games at
us chest champs calm